look closely and you'll see James
Charles stepping out for his first big
appearance following his recent bitter
feud on Tuesday James attended Kylie
Jenner's launch party for her skincare
line
Kylie skin now this is a big deal
because it marks the 19 year old
vloggers first major public appearance
following his viral feud with toddy
Westbrook and Jeffrey star but I was
just like so gutted the three were at
odds over a number of things apparently
but their friendships seemingly blew up
over James's support of sugar bear hair
a company that competes with Toddy's own
vitamin Line get off your high horse and
have some respect
uh-huh all this over gummy vitamins
people moving along James offered up an
apology I'm sorry for everything that is
going on and in the wake of the drama
Kylie was rumored to have unfollowed him
guys nothing is as savage as an unfollow
him I write anywho after a lot of back
and forth
James Jeffrey and toddy have since
called a truce I'm just hoping that we
can leave it at that and close this up
and that people can drop this and move
forward and let some actual healing
happen and it seems like any beef
between James and Kylie is totally a
thing of the past because check it out
that's James in the background of one of
her Instagram story posts James can be
seen laughing at the bar with a group of
people and because the event was pink
hewed complete with branded food a
bathtub to pose in a skating rink pink
drinks and even pink sushi James showed
up on 'theme rocking a pink suit
naturally and while James didn't post
any pics with Kylie herself he did share
this selfie with Kylie's momager Kris
Jenner when each II caught up with James
last year he actually gushed about his
quote amazing relationship with the
kardashian-jenner clan
his mad respect for Chris she's a genius
and like what just might what anybody
seems to think building a business is
probably the best help that anybody can
have and being able to like leverage
your name for likeness and build a brand
around it hello
that's so smart and so good and just
check out what he had to say about Kylie
it was just really amazing to see
somebody else in the space working
really hard and just making it at a
young age she's a huge inspiration to me
and it's just been I definitely had a
similar experience to her in the sense
that people just love to tear you down
and bash you and stuff it she she's a
great role model of course et will be
here to keep you in the know on all
things Kardashian's Jenner's and James
Charles so be sure to keep it locked
right here until next time I'm Haley
Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]